student protesters at Howard University
are entering their fifth straight day
occupying the school's administrative
building the group Howard University
resists is leading this protest it
started after an anonymous blog post
alleged that nearly a million dollars in
financial aid money was misused
protesters now have a list of nine
demands for the university Jan Crawford
is at Howard the campus in Washington DC
right now to bring us up to date Jan
good morning good morning so organizers
say they're only going to allow students
and maintenance workers into this
building and last night student leaders
spent more than five hours negotiating
with board members among their demands
adequate housing disarming campus police
and even the resignation of the
university's president
[Applause]
and speaking circles hundreds of
students have held the administration
building hostage living there since
Thursday to get the university to listen
to their demands they've received
support through social media and
donations of food and water the sit-in
started after reports that the president
dr. Wayne Frederic knew about the
embezzlement of nearly 1 million dollars
in the financial aid office to employees
through an authorized grants the
university acknowledged they launched an
investigation and then fired six
employees the students say they should
have been more transparent Friday the
university Student Association back
their demands Bryant is one of the
organizers with hu resist this
university needs real institutional
change
on Saturday the Board of Trustees agreed
to one of the group's demands about
adequate housing for students under 21
but it says it won't stop until all nine
are met we are prepared to occupy the
administration building until we are
more than satisfied that our demands
have been met fifty years ago another
sit-in was held to challenge the
administration after four days their
grievances were heard we are carrying on
the tradition of Howard the tradition of
activism the tradition of resistance to
oppression and the university should
recognize that now some alumni from that
1968 protest have come here to help the
students with their sit-in but the
Alumni Association for the University
says it supports the president and
rejects all calls for his resignation
Fionna stirred a lot of controversy
there Jam thank you